[Music]
speaking of babies where in the world
are beyonce and jay z's twins but here's
the thing
did former President Barack Obama just
give away the babies genders Jay and I
are also fools for our daughters
although he's gonna have me beat once
those two twins show up the former
president made the comment during a
video tribute for jay-z's induction into
the Songwriters Hall of Fame and it had
the Beehive buzzing that since the
Obamas have two girls and jay-z and
Beyonce have one the only way jay-z
could beat the former president is if he
had twin girls he's gonna have me beat
once those two twins show up but it may
have just been some confusing word
choices a source tells us former
President Obama doesn't know the gender
of jay-z and Beyonce's twins and when he
said he's got me beat with twins he
simply meant that jay-z and Beyonce will
have more children than him pretty soon
here's another clue that the beyonce
baby news could break at any moment
jay-z was scheduled to attend that
induction ceremony in Los Angeles last
night but he didn't go the speculation
is that he was at beyonce side at UCLA
Medical Center his SUV was spotted there
today as it has been every day since
Tuesday